hey guys we're mid-october and we're
headed to the trenches and this week's
new releases battlefield one is taking
us back to the simpler times of World
War one where you had to wait to shoot
until you could see the whites of their
eyes and shovels were considered a
weapon other world war one weapons
included bolt-action rifles automatic
and semi-automatic rifles artillery
flamethrowers and good old-fashioned
mustard gas but you're also traveling in
style in this game with heavy tanks
armored trucks by plane aircraft
battleships and of course Zeppelin's but
you can give all those up for
straight-up good old-fashioned horses
the game will launch with 9 maps and six
modes which include conquest domination
operations rush team deathmatch and war
pigeons in a game for the birds players
must secure war pigeons and then use
them to call in for an artillery strike
you're going back to the past on the
21st now if you want to kill people but
you want to see it from far far away
consider strategy game sid meier's civ 6
as you might have guessed it's going to
feel similar to the other sid games but
because it's being developed by the
teams that made the expansions you're
going to find a lot of similarities
there city improvements such as military
installations are now on stack from the
main city tile this encourages players
to add improvements to other types of
terrain the game also uses a good
old-fashioned drawn map approach to
illustrate tiles that have yet to be
explored make your civilization reign
supreme by following those 4 x's explore
expand exploit and exterminate build
your army and add technologies to
eventually rule over the whole planet
the world is yours on the 21st lego
lovers and Harry Potter enthusiasts
rejoice lego harry potter years 1
through 4 is coming out to cover the
first four films in the harry potter
series just like in every lego game
you'll be collecting exploring and
solving puzzles you also get
spell-casting and potion making and yes
you can turn someone into a frog you'll
visit the leaky cauldron as a central
hub for purchasing unlockable extras and
returning to previous levels and of
course you'll be hanging out at Hogwarts
to find unlockable characters found by
pick
up hidden portraits for harry potter and
LEGO fans it's a win-win and you can
raise your wand on the 21st the kids are
getting Skylanders imagine ators and
there's something different this time
players can create their own characters
known as imagine aters everything else
is pretty much the same you're solving
puzzles your platforming you're fighting
you get to put your little Skylander toy
figurine on the portal of power and
there's multiplayer all that stuff is
the same but now players can select a
battle class and an elemental class and
then customize the names voices powers
appearances and colors even the sizes of
their imagine a ters it's pretty cool
and if you have an unimaginative child
they can just choose one that's randomly
generated most importantly both crash
bandicoot and dr. neocortex will appear
as guest characters and yes crash will
have zone level oh yeah finally Batman
returned to Arkham features remastered
versions of Arkham Asylum and Arkham
City using the Unreal Engine 4 this is
for the PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
additionally both games include all
previously released downloadable content
and features improved graphics upgraded
models and environments and improvements
in the lighting effects and shaders for
both games if you're a fan of the bat
and you want to relive that series this
is a no brainer you become the bat on
the 21st and that's all I have for you
this week do you remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
sometimes those change I'll see you guys
again next week